our only like real Jewish uh like
Authority is Sephardic yeah and so he
gives us like his Sephardic La version
of Judaism it's part of your trash
what is it what's the difference between
you Jew and that Jew well he'll never
wears [ __ ] yamaka out except on
Shabbos he's [ __ ] half half Jews
I take care of their bread they don't
cut it they're animals dude they're not
like they're not like full-on they are
tough for them yeah oh they're tougher
tougher sometimes sometimes he does
bacon no no no he's not religious that's
the biggest daddy eats a lot of bacon no
there's one food where art food is
better afterwards the food is better
they lost my jeans
you have to worry about God as much
you guys all like Israeli food and it's
mainly it's mostly spartic yeah look
there's a Jewish Olympics 100 meter dash
who wins
we're actually good like middle distance
but you guys I mean some of the long
game yeah I will say the one thing I
realized later johori turned me on to
this is that you guys didn't have the
Holocaust yeah didn't have it it's Syria
and Iran and Jordan just never got there
so they're there's this deep close
historical thing what
Russians the Muslims the Muslims
protected the Jews yeah well no ottoman
was World War One right but yeah they
were living in these they were like no
no no like like Moroccans love their
Muslim King like they are very Moroccan
Jews I mean
remember yes we did not have anything
close to what the Holocaust was but then
they did also get mainly kicked out of
Maine but that was actually oh come on
tears for Palestine but you're talking
about you getting kicked out of some
place this guy talking about the
Holocaust all the time you mean go
through it tell me hey slavery was rough
for me tell me which supporting Jews are
still living interesting
I'm just curious can African
[Music]
Americans not black people like Africans
that just move here they talk about
slavery in the same way that
African-Americans like black people in
America are the distance of slaves that
was slavery in Africa as well yeah but
from y'all I'd be interested later so
they have slavery there
racism is not the issue right everybody
is going to experience some foreign
these unchosen little losers
in the old days like in Israel because
it was like all Jews for a while we were
almost on a point here yeah and as far
as hated each other like and then my dad
said Safari was dating his sister and
then uh a bunch of their friends like
beat that guy up and put him in the
hospital whoa no [ __ ] smart he's
gonna do now he's like I don't know what
we were thinking about that that was
nuts people feel about all of our [ __ ]
them yeah that's like a [ __ ] Irish
Catholic not in my neighborhood
it's just a different time
can they complain about the Holocaust in
the same way right that was what we're
trying to get at because there's
conferences
you've taken away their abilities exists
if you take away their a way to complain
censorship
I'm just curious I'm just saying I'm
just saying can they complain the same
way because they did not experience it
it's not something that they know coming
after juice all of them
well not all right
oh our guys can blend it in you can go
to Mexico and blend in yeah go to North
Africa really blend in bruh yeah I can't
really blend in I was in I was in um
Amsterdam and my friend Paul Morrison we
were walking to some bar whatever and
this this big Nigerian bouncer he's just
like uh I did whatever I was like okay
go Shalom my brother to me
like sight unseen yeah no they're gonna
find you but that is an interesting
point yeah that is really yeah you can't
really complain about the homework you
can't technically speaking technically
speaking people claim on interest rates
you can't do that
and have if you
if you had kind of segregated if I
walked into a random synagogue is there
like a sephardum and then
what do you say when the Safari room
goes ah the Holocaust was so horrible
yeah what do you say when they say what
like when they're like oh the Holocaust
was so hard for us and like our people
yeah what was her reading about it and
stuff
well that diary is very depressing
uh yeah we had to read it too I'm just
is there any conversation this is this
is no we never really talked about to be
honest though why wouldn't they want us
to be protective of uh of that story we
do our [ __ ] work to do it that's a
good why didn't they come bust down and
[ __ ] with y'all like help y'all just
help us yeah yeah like sorry my my uh
what about the man's list yeah my father
fought in World War One suck a dick he
was in trenches
later sequel just hide come on son
that's wild dog look how they do all the
stuff
oh our food is so good roast these
little uh
yeah like an actual Survivor though I've
heard I've heard sephardics say that
they survived the Holocaust what I
I what they've said that wait well we
survived the hall like everyone oh I'm
so sorry I gotta survived 9 11. yeah
exactly yeah maybe it would have
something would have happened had we not
been kicked out of Europe in 1492 thank
you again
yeah
you guys were selfish why didn't you go
east like them you guys went South
because you want to be near the water
you know hey that you can complain about
14 days
42. what happens you know what
as we learn more and more about cultures
like Jews are not a monolith there are
Jews that have experienced struggle and
then there are others and it's fine
that's okay that's okay I'm learning
today yeah I think that's beautiful so
what's the ranking of Jews is there is
there a power ranking okay so after
going through this extreme struggle yeah
they make more money Jordan Ash is all
them but but we don't know
live in and pay rents are Syrian juice
in your house okay listen I live in Deal
New Jersey you live in deals no no
pay hold on it's called deals
[Music]
yes
you're not even trying to I know you're
not sure
I can't I'm a rocket you gotta be
serious to be there okay yeah yeah even
yeah there's some like there's some like
that series of Moroccan Jews don't think
they're better or worse yeah it's like
all you guys you guys are like no we're
too Blended we don't even know anymore
yeah but but it was very nice of you to
actually finally make Israel for them
because they couldn't do it actually we
built it that was really used us to
build it it was really cool that the
ashkenazis went in there I was like get
enough credit for that right we don't
need this
[Laughter]
yeah I don't wow
on this food [ __ ] that they took from
the Muslims if you really want to if you
really wanted to yeah what did they do
Kanye get at me let's band together
the right juice
I'll rewrite yourself I'll spell check
that's a problem
you wouldn't get these [ __ ] Smarties
once and for all no he's actually only
married he doesn't Holocaust never
happened
[Applause]
wow
you need to team up start a bank
together
this is great this is I think we've
actually gotten somewhere this is
beautiful and I'm glad that you're
learning more thank you about your
history yeah yeah that kush life that
you were living in them 40s man wouldn't
it be nice from people thinking that you
you're Jewish I think you've actually
made oh yeah it's so much benefit I get
all the anti-Semitism and none of the
benefits of being Jewish none of the
loans yeah exactly yeah I've had so many
people I'm like he's not Jewish not be
wrong I'm not wrong you know you're
Jewish dude he does not you know you're
Jews yeah
[Music]
listen I know and I experience the Jew
hate they won't they won't they want
they're like they think I'm Jewish so
they anybody who hates Jews will hate me
right right right then I don't have you
know the great ashkenazis to protect me
you don't have the intelligence the
intelligence of the ashkenazis I just
got this guy brain
for yourself that's not bad yeah